un invité de marque au cinéma ugc cyrano
de versailles le skipper versailles et
éric bellion est venu présenter en avant
première son film comme un seul homme le
long métrage d'une heure 25 autres à son
vendée globe 2010 est un tour du monde
en solitaire
donc c'est tout ce qui se passe quand on
perd le bateau de vue et jusqu'à ce
qu'on le redécouvre et donc c'est tout
ce cheminement intérieur le fait d'aller
au delà de sa peur de se rencontrer et
j'essaie de le raconter avec le plus de
sincérité possible je crois que des
moments très forts parce que ça c'est
une aventure ultime
moi j'avais jamais fait de solitaire
avant de partir sur le vendée globe
donc tout est une découverte chaque jour
est une aventure pour immerger au
maximum le public le skipper s'est filmé
pendant plus de cinquante heures à
l'aide d'une caméra miniature en
parallèle de ces manoeuvres dans les
vagues
j'ai pas ressenti le fait que ça me
prenne trop de temps c'est vraiment
quelque chose que je voulais donc
c'était pour moi aussi important que
bien faire marcher mon bateau et puis
j'avais des caméras facilement
atteignables donc je pouvais les
déclencher quand j'avais quelque chose à
dire ou quand je ressentais quelque
chose de fort je voulais vraiment
communiquer c'était très important pour
moi de le partager au maximum à la
sortie de ce film première réaction du
public versé y est c'est enfin c'est
quelqu'un d'assez original et je trouve
que c'est sympa de pouvoir nous faire
partager ce qu'il a vécu la difficulté
de la course comme ça c'est de ne pas
partager ces moments là il a eu une
approche de ce tour du monde avec une
philosophie finalement sur sa façon
d'appréhender ces difficultés
sa relation avec son bateau sa relation
de la solitude ça me parle beaucoup
la sortie en salles officielle du film
est programmée le 13 février prochain
sur tout le territoire français